طائرة بدون طيار إيرانية الصنع ذات رأس شاه أطلقتها
القوات الروسية تتجه نحو
نظام دفاع جوي أوكراني خاطئ
احتفل به الجنود الأوكرانيون بسرعة.
ما فاته الروس هو أن هذا
نظام دفاع جوي مزيف
جزء من ترسانة كاملة من الأفخاخ الخداعية التي
ظهرت في جميع أنحاء البلاد
وهمية  أسلحة رخيصة الصنع بقدر ما
هي مفيدة لنشر مدفع
هاوتزر علجوم أمريكي يكلف ما بين 2
إلى 4 ملايين دولار، هذا المدفع كلفنا
ألف دولار لجعله
يتكون أساسًا من أنابيب الصرف، لكن
النقطة المهمة هي في كل مرة واحدة من هذه  لقد تم
ضربها، إنها ضربة حقيقية تم الحفاظ عليها، وقد
كلف الروس وقتًا وطاقة
ومالًا للتغلب على
التحدي الذي تواجهه شركة مصانع الصلب هذه
التي لا علاقة لها
بصناعة الأسلحة على الإطلاق، وتحديث تصميماتها
لمواكبة الأسلحة الأكثر تطورًا من أي وقت مضى.
وصولهم إلى أوكرانيا
على الرغم من القتال على طول
الجبهة الشرقية كان صعبًا.
يعترف المسؤولون الأوكرانيون
بأن الغابة الواقعة خارج بلدة
كريمينا الشرقية كانت ساحة معركة خلال
معظم فترات الحرب، لكن
الهجوم المضاد جعل
المعارك اليومية أكثر حدة.
ميكويلياك، قائد القوات الخاصة،
عاد للتو من هناك مع
رجاله،
إحدى الدبابات الروسية، تعرضت وحدته
لهجوم قريب في وقت مبكر من الحرب، ويقول إن
نقص الذخيرة كان أمرًا مزمنًا في
هذه الحرب في أوكرانيا، ويوضح أنه كان عليه
استخدام الإبداع كما هو الحال  يحمل الخطوط
الأجنبية
جزءًا من هذا الجهد يحدث بعيدًا
عن الخطوط الأمامية في مصانع مثل
هذا، إتقان فن السلاح المزيف
مقياس نجاح كل شرك ومدى
سرعة تدميره مرة واحدة في الميدان
ميليسا بلسيانين في وسط أوكرانيا
لدينا  فيديو درامي لجهود الإنقاذ
بعد ضربة روسية في شمال شرق
أوكرانيا ويظهر عمال الطوارئ وهم
يخمدون حريقًا ثم يحفرون
تحت الأنقاض بعد أن
ضرب صاروخ كروز مدينة سومي يوم الجمعة،
ويقول المسؤولون إن ثلاثة أشخاص أصيبوا،
من بينهم اثنان تم سحبهما من تحت
مبنى دمره الهجوم
في وقت سابق من اليوم،
تُظهر هذه اللقطات اللحظة التي
أصاب فيها صاروخ آخر
مسقط رأس الرئيس فلاديمير زيلينسكي وضرب الصاروخ
وسط مدينة كيد بيوتي مما أسفر عن مقتل
شخص واحد وإصابة 54 آخرين، كما
تقول أوكرانيا إن 10 مبانٍ على الأقل قد تضررت بسبب الصواريخ الروسية  كما
قتلت ثلاثة أشخاص في ابنها
وجرحت آخرين